hi there Steve Kaufman here and today I
am going to talk about Chinese learning
Chinese remember I said that once a week
I will put out a video in a language
other than English so I'll have my two
videos in English and one in another
language and following at least for the
next little while following the video in
that language I'll talk a little bit
about learning that language so today
I'll talk a little bit about learning
Chinese next week I'll probably speak in
French and I'll follow that up with a
little bit about learning French all
right
learning Chinese I studied Chinese in
1968 I was with the Canadian government
Ministry of trade and commerce camera
that was about to recognize the People's
Republic of China I was working for them
they sent me to Hong Kong to learn
Mandarin I couldn't go to the mainland
because they were in the throes of the
Cultural Revolution I couldn't go to
Taiwan because that would not have been
acceptable I had a choice I could have
gone to Monterey California and had a
great time surfing or go to Hong Kong
and study Mandarin there so I chose the
latter and I have never regretted it
um the thing about Chinese less so now
then then is that it strikes us if we
are say speakers of European languages
as sort of very exotic how can I learn
the language that from a culture that's
so different from my own and I would
imagine that to some extent people from
different cultures Asian cultures or
others may have the same attitude
towards or towards learning European or
Middle Eastern or Central Asian
languages I don't know but one of my
friends at that time said you know what
if he can't learn Chinese and at that
point I had learned French so I knew I
could learn one other language and I
felt pretty confident
I could learn another one I guess what I
have found through my Chinese learning
is that Chinese culture while it's
fascinating and rich and I was entirely
unaware of it before I started studying
Chinese once you get into the language
it's not so inscrutable it's not so
strange
it becomes a part of you just like any
other language that you learn you enter
that world you enjoy it you wallow in it
you discover it you climb all over it
it's a very positive experience Chinese
has two outstanding difficulties and a
number of things that make it easy the
two outstanding difficulties are the
need to learn Chinese characters and the
tones right up front those are the two
big problems after that it's downhill I
recommend that you begin by say for the
first month and certainly that's what I
did I listen to simple dialogues and I
relied on a romanized version of Chinese
so for the first month I didn't do any
characters in those days we you you will
use wave Giles which actually I prefer
to pinyin but it's not a big deal either
way it seems that the world has
standardized now on pinyin which is the
form of romanization developed on the
mainland it has a few strange things
like q is pronounced cha and x is
pronounced it's a sir like a somewhere
between an S and s H sound so you might
meet someone who's give you their name
card I mean I don't know why they do
this it means that if an Chinese person
gives you their name card and their name
is you know Tran or something qu a n is
hello mr. Kwon I don't know why they've
done that but that's what they've done
so you have to get used to it characters
so therefore after a month of pinyin
which allows you to get used to opinion
because it's very useful to have the
pinyin and to learn some of the
idiosyncrasies tackle the characters
I've explained very often how I learned
character
I used to have these Chinese checkered
exercise books and I'd have flashcards
and I'd pick out the first flashcard of
a character I'd write it out ten times
then put the meaning or the sound the
pronunciation but two or three columns
over and then I take the second card and
write it out 10 or 20 times and continue
doing that until I ran into the first
card the pronunciation of the meaning
again then I wrote it out ten times and
then I put it across you know three or
two or three commas further over so it's
a very basic kind of call it spaced
repetition system nowadays there are
many more modern effective ways of
learning characters I got to the point I
started at learning ten a day I got up
to 30 a day with the understanding that
you're going to forget two-thirds of
what you learn so I had to keep on
reshuffling the learned cards back into
my deck because you have to learn and
relearn learn and relearn it's like so
much in language learning at first it
seems impossible I mean the character
for I walk has like I don't know how
many strokes in it you got to remember
I'm your yeah yeah I mean it seems
impossible but it's amazing what the
brain will eventually learn if you stay
with it and the big thing with learning
characters is it's true for all I'm
learning but especially for characters
do it every day every day just you know
that salami or Bologna salami slice
technique if you just keep doing it hey
you won't slip back as much you won't
forget as much and you'll eventually get
there and I use my technique for the
first thousand characters and thereafter
with enough reading and you know when I
encounter a new power character you know
writing it out a few times eventually
they start to stick because you start to
become more familiar with them you know
it's like everything in language during
the more things that you are now
familiar with the more things you notice
so you notice the components of the
characters when I first started them
they I was told that these are the
radicals these are the components that
represent you know water or metal or
something it was meaningless to me but
after a while you start to see those
things and so it becomes easier and
easier to learn the characters you just
have to
stay there course all right some people
say should you learn traditional or or
simplified it depends where you're going
to be but at the very least learn
simplified if you're going to be
involved with mainland China the vast
majority of Chinese people in the world
use the simplified system I started with
the traditional and then move to
simplified which is actually an easy way
to go because once you have the
traditional you can easily learn the
simplified it's kind of handy to have
both if you're in Taiwan or Hong Kong
you can pick up a newspaper read it and
understand it the language itself once
you get past okay the tones here again
when you learn the language every word
that you learn in the dictionary or in
the pinyin will have a pone mark so the
four tones are for use ma ma ma ma ma so
you have sort of a high flat tone ma ma
which is actually starts a little lords
ma ma ma now depending how these words
show up together some of those tones
actually modify themselves a little bit
and so ultimately you end up learning
the tones as part of little phrases or
little because again one other thing in
Chinese is a word as we understand a
word like understand or say improve it's
a good example improve or change
okay so guide yeah guys change en is
also changed guide then guy Shan is to
improve sugai is to revise so most of
the words in Chinese are actually
composed of two or three characters and
if you know one or two of the characters
and you see how they're now connected
with some other character you can kind
of intuitively figure out the meaning or
at least the words are easier to
remember so the more characters you have
for every character you have you
actually potentially have three or four
or five words because these now can be
combined like building blocks with other
characters to form two character or
three character
or even phrases so I digressed a bit
from the tone so after a while you
realize that you kind of have to learn
the tones not so much as individual you
know characteristics of each single
character but rather as part of phrases
because that way you get into the
intonation and because it's very
difficult while speaking every time you
go to use a word that trying to
remembers its first on second talk it's
very difficult to do but if you're used
to certain phrases and a certain
intonation of these phrases you'll
eventually start improving and you don't
want to be so tongue-tied and hung up
about the tones that you can't speak so
I for example found that my tones
improved over time was a constant battle
I might have eight hitting them 40% at
first and it just drives me moved up and
made out now at 80% when I get excited
and I want to emphasize something that's
actually a third tone or like yo Mayo
like do you have your I might hate you
because I'm keen to say something and
then my inclination in English to put
the tone where the emphasis is takes
over and I no longer use the tone as in
Chinese to indicate meaning remember
that we have tones in English there's
nothing unique or difficult or strange
about having tones in English we use
tones for emphasis in the sentence but
in Chinese they use tones ma ma ma ma to
differentiate meaning and so at times we
have a tendency when we're speaking to
want to use intonation for emphasis
rather than for the meaning of the words
but you have to believe that you'll
eventually get better at it and not get
too hung up about it in terms of the
structure the structure of Chinese it's
actually very rational I think it's a
very you know in its simplicity it's a
very efficient language so you go
Nietzsche okay I go watch you you don't
go near budge in here Boo is actually
fourth tone but if it's boo too because
the choose a fourth on it becomes second
don't worry about it but it helps me
Poochie then are you going need to butch
it you go not go so you know fairly
straightforward stuff in as in every
language you should focus on learning
the W words why where when etc you know
like why is way shoma and then because
you know Asia the UN way too much you
know you learned some of these key
connector words learn I spent a lot of
time in Chinese learning key phrases you
know all the things having to do with
why because although you know
Suellen is although swear and some Shama
Shama is what so straight as yama what -
I still want to blah blah blah or even
though Joe Swan de da da da why I did so
there's a whole bunch of these patterns
the big thing for me in Chinese was
patterns and if I get a pattern I want
to find ten examples of those patterns
and then look for them in my listening
and reading all of the grammatical
explanations that I found in Chinese
grammar books I can't remember a single
word a single term that they invent to
describe Chinese grammar all I focused
on was patterns particularly as regards
the question words why when where et
cetera and the connector words you know
the although you know however and all
those kinds of words one little trick in
Chinese that the they don't really have
relative pronouns so that if instead of
saying the house which is on the hill
they'll say the on the hill house
and there's a little connector word the
and you gotta use to that but by and
large the grammar is pretty
straightforward vocabulary building once
you have characters is pretty
straightforward
ah this idea of sort of inscrutable
exotic strange you quickly get over that
I mean that's there with any language
initially perhaps more so of the Chinese
but once you get into it it becomes your
language and there's so much interesting
stuff when I study Chinese
we did a lot of reading of you know
German model and that stuff because the
Cultural Revolution was on him so we got
a real sense of the whole political Gang
of Four and stuff that was going on in
China but what was particularly
fascinating and I really recommend once
your Chinese improves is the literature
of the 20s and 30s because what happened
to China is you had this the the
traditional China actually was a foreign
dynasty the Ching dynasty which ruled
China and very traditional with all of
their traditional Confucian is stand
Buddhist and all of the traditional
culture somewhat isolationist if you
want all of a sudden bang run smack dab
into the Western world and in 1911 there
is what they call a sort of Shanghai go
means revolution and there is a Republic
and then there's the struggles with
warlords and all this kind of stuff it
is actually it's quite astounding to me
how quickly but we could call sort of
modern almost western-style
intellectuals thinkers political
thinkers novelists and there was this
outpouring of intellectual production in
China through the 20s 30s despite the
fact that there were you know warlords
fighting and the basically continuous
civil war between the Communists and the
Nationalists invasion from Japan they
had you know four colonies I mean it was
a mess
hunger famines and floods and yet there
was this outstanding intellectual
outpouring and that is some of the most
interesting Chinese to read to me I
would also wonder one day get back to my
Chinese in order to read more about
Chinese history because there are so
many stories from Chinese history and
Chinese people are very much aware of
stories that come out of Chinese history
from 2,000 years ago and they make
reference to this and of course I
haven't had the time to spend on Chinese
because I studied it 45 years ago and
since then I've lived in Japan and I've
learned other languages and really
haven't spent enough time with Chinese
but all of that world awaits you not to
mention the modern Chinese and this is
one other thing
I'll end up with and that is that when I
study Chinese mainland China was kind of
closed it was you know Mao is China
people were afraid to talk to you
whereas now you can go there you can
make friends you can go to restaurants
to bars you know it's modernizing
there's trains there's their problems
there's corruption pollution and lack of
democracy and all those other things but
it's it's alive and and the Chinese are
very approachable there they have their
pluses and minuses like every national
group they're endearing qualities and
they're less enduring qualities when
we're talking generalities and yet you
find individuals with all kinds of
different personalities but generally
speaking I say that they are quite
approachable they love to talk and if
you speak their language they're
extremely supportive so there you have
it a brief intro to Chinese and I wish
you all the best of luck in learning
Chinese bye for now